keeping our united kingdom strong means
a fair settlement for all four corners
of these islands we do not support
English nationalists we do not want an
English Parliament this manifesto simply
recognizes that the Democratic picture
has got more complicated in the United
Kingdom and these plans are not
one-size-fits-all they are tailor made
for each part of England on the NHS our
guarantee is to increase spending in
England every year and to provide seven
days a week access to your GP and to
continue to invest in our life-saving
cancer drugs fund education our
guarantee is to maintain the amount of
money that follows each child into the
school to lift the cap on University
places and to fund three million
apprenticeships will extend the right to
buy to housing association tenants and
we will build 200,000 new starter homes
twenty percent below the market price
the first time buyers under the age of
40 there's the guarantee of 30 hours of
free childcare two working parents of
three and four-year-olds for everyone
over 75 they guarantee of a same-day
appointment at your GP if you need one
the vote conservative on May the 7th a
vote for anyone else makes an Ed
Miliband SNP government more likely
which would put all of these things at
risk only a strong conservative
government will deliver for you and your
family